willkommen zurück hierbei bild live und
das ist eine nachricht die deutschland
bewegt und über die gesprochen wird denn
tennis legende boris becker ist im knast
und das hier sind die exklusiven bilder
von boris beckers neuem zuhause und das
für mindestens 15 monate das erste
wochenende die ersten nächte der erste
neue ganz neue alltag für den gefallenen
tennishelden frühstück hinter gittern
mittagessen hinter mauern geregeltes
aufstehen geregelte nachtruhe anstatt
exklusive restaurants und nightline
alisa du sagst es 15 monate mindestens
und das auch nur bei guter führung denn
verurteilt ist boris becker ja zu einer
freiheitsstrafe von zwei jahren und
sechs monaten
ja und seine letzten minuten in freiheit
die wollen wir uns auch noch mal
anschauen boris becker am freitag kommt
er gegen 12 uhr 30 deutscher zeit mit
freundin lillian hand in hand bei
gericht an der tennisheld trägt eine
krawatte in den farben von wimbledon da
hat er noch gehofft und gebangt gebracht
hat es bekanntlich nichts
ja und jetzt wollen wir mit einem mann
sprechen der ganz genau weiß wie es
hinter diesen mauern zugeht chris atkins
ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet hätten sie
saßen ja auch genau in diesem knast ein
in dem boris jetzt ist was ist das für
ein gefängnis
am besten
man in der zeit
nicht viel gemacht worden um sie
wirklich grauen haare nicht funktioniert
der standard ist ziemlich niedrig war
als integrationsprobleme mit die
sanitäranlagen wenig also alles fällt
auseinander um einen rum
das hört sich nicht gerade einladend an
können sie jetzt noch mal beschreiben
wie diese zelle ganz genau von innen
aussieht
das volk sei kein schimmel sind ja das
ist witzig auch ein eher schlechter drin
weiß hat mich unwohl gefühlt die einzig
sein so für eine person
konzipiert aber weil dazu ihre leute
drin sind schaffen jetzt frei in jeder
zelle
ungefähr acht meter lang und sieben
weitere ist cm und man schläft in
stockbetten
utility so und das klo ist da eben auch
mit drin die toilette und ganz seinen
schlaf
und dann gibt es noch eine kleine halb
tisch oder dass ein waschbecken das ist
doch eklig und die farbe kommt von den
wänden runter also es ist echt eklig und
sie kam ja auch nicht aus dem
kriminellen milieu sondern wurden wegen
eines steuervergehens verurteilt genauso
wie boris kommen sie aus einer anderen
welt was glauben sie wird es ihm dort
jetzt ergehen
am anfang das ist ein riesenschock haben
ist erhöht das ganze seite ist ich war
noch nie im gefängnis erwischen reform
es ist wie wenn man einen eiswürfel
nimmt ein heißes bad reinwirft wirklich
fertig schreiben denn für das eigene
nervensystem aber auch für die eigenen
sinne weil wir wahnsinnig laut
wir haben das dann immer beirut im land
war desto wahnsinnig geräuschvoll ist
und voller leute die auch spinnen die
vielleicht gegenseitig sind
absolut probleme haben die sauer sind
die zorn verspüren und die machen
einfach immer geräusche
wie sieht der tag eines häftlings dort
aus yogakursen geräusche von dem sie
gerade gesprochen haben können sie uns
ein bisschen beschreiben was ist da
alles gibt
was sie da gelesen haben ganz ehrlich
ist das offizielle pamphlet darüber
riester ist aber das ist tatsächlich
groß gegenteil vom echten leben im
gefängnis bringen es gibt einfach kein
geld das ganze bringt gefängnissystem
hat kein geld deswegen sage ich ganz
ehrlich es gibt auch kein yoga in die
wege leiten oder core oder so möglichst
viel zu wenig menschen sind dort
angestellt und die meisten leute sind
eigentlich den ganzen tag in diesem fall
eingesperrt eingeschlossen das ist es
dahin kommt erst ein paar tage für 23
stunden am tag in dieser zelle sein und
sicher kein yoga machen
kein yoga also aber es gibt sicherlich
gewalt in diesem
entweder ist ein sehr gewalttätige fans
nicht anders sagen gefangen wir fangen
doch fragen rosentreter und auch eine
selbstverletzung leider von den menschen
dort erging sich am ende selbst um grad
im emsland viele ritzen sich schneidet
letztendlich selbst ja es gibt alle
arten von gewalt
buch ganz schön heftig vielen dank herr
atkins für diese ausführung nur ein
weiter darüber sprechen unser reporter
john puthenpurackal ist uns jetzt live
aus london zugeschaltet john weiß man
denn inzwischen wie boris becker diese
erst nächte im knast verbracht hat wie
es ihnen geht
ja ich könnte am samstag mit einem
mitarbeiter kurz sprechender mehr
bestätigt hat dass zum einen bruce
becker in portsmouth untergebracht ist
zumal dann hat irgendwie auch gesagt ihm
geht es den umständen entsprechend gut
er ist aktuell nach unserer information
im wing vom des gefängnisses
untergebracht
der steht quasi für die willkommens
einheit des gefängnisses das ist die
sektion wo häftlinge am anfang
untergebracht werden dort werden
medizinische checks durchgeführt dort
wird eine einführung gegeben und dort
werden sie auch untergebracht werden sie
von den anderen gefangenen abgesondert
werden sollen warum soll boris von den
anderen gefangenen abgesondert werden
willkommens einer klingt ja erstmal
recht positiv wir haben vorhin chris
atkins gehört der im gleichen gefängnis
eingesessen hat wobei es jetzt ist der
hat eben berichtet dass es da ganz und
gar nicht einladend zugeht
dann muss dazu sagen tatsächlich auch
der übrigen ist nicht ganz einladend
chris atkins hat diesen bereich den
spitznamen beirut gegeben aufgrund des
lärms aufgrund dieser menschen die er
dort gesehen ab drogenabhängigen
menschen mit gesundheitlichen mentalen
problemen die ein entgegenkommen das ist
natürlich dann erst mal auch ein shop
kleinen menschen wie boris becker der
aus einer ganz anderen welt kommt und
man kann es erst mal so sagen es ist
auch eine gewisse eingewöhnungsphase bzw
er wird abgesondert und beobachtet zu
werden das gilt auch für andere
häftlinge erst dort untergebracht
mithäftling die gerade im begriff sind
entlassen zu werden zu werden er ist
dort untergebracht mit menschen die neu
angekommenen sind man schaut sich
erstmal wie gesagt gesundheitliche
punkte an und natürlich ist das auch am
anfang ein mentaler schutz gegenüber
gefangenen die schon lange drin sind und
eventuell keine hemmungen haben einen so
einen prominenten anzugehen denn durch
seine prominenz hat boris einen
risikofaktor im gefängnis und natürlich
möchte das gefängnis alles verhindern
dass ihm etwas dort passieren könnte
denkbar ist es dann auch mit diesem
hintergrund dass boris becker eventuell
dann eine art job anfängt im knast zum
beispiel als fitnesstrainer in gin das
wäre ja denkbar und ist eigentlich ja
auch eine sehr begehrter job im knast
oder
ja also natürlich der beste job den man
kriegen kann ich möchte da eine ganz
ehrliche einschätzung geben so nach den
gesprächen die ich in den vergangenen
tagen geführt habe halte ich das in
brands dürfte ziemlich unwahrscheinlich
denn monster hat zum einen nicht
wirklich die ausstattung dafür da jetzt
ein geregeltes training oder ein
tennistraining zu geben was eventuell
vorstellbar ist dass boris becker bei
einer verlegung in ein kleines gefängnis
in ein moderneres gefängnis dass er dort
so einen job annehmen könnte aber in
wansdorf selber halte ich das für
ziemlich ausgeschlossen sein alltag wird
größtenteils hinter
gittern in seiner zelle stattfinden wo
er bis zu 20 stunden verbringen muss
ausgenommen natürlich vielleicht mal
eine stunde freigang das wird sein
alltag sein und von job davon gehe ich
jetzt aus dem bett keinen geregelten job
danach gehen weil einfach die
kapazitäten natürlich da sind
dankeschön für diese information
zahlreiche promis haben sich inzwischen
ebenfalls zum fall boris becker
geäußerte darunter unter anderem der
tennisspieler novak djokovic und auch
bayerns ministerpräsident
markus söder der ihn als jugendidol
sieht
frances becker ist ein freund ein
langjähriger freund er war für drei vier
jahre mein trainer wir waren uns sehr
nahe und er hat viel zu meinem erfolg
beigetragen es bricht mir das herz ich
weiß nicht was ich noch dazu sagen soll
ich möchte nicht ins detail gehen
nicht nur er ist emotional bewegt im
rahmen der bmw open in münchen da haben
wir auch mit ex nationaltorwart jens
lehmann gesprochen der sich auch sehr
emotional über dieses becker urteil
zeigt er hat ist natürlich ein schock es
tut mir einerseits menschlich sehr weh
weil ich kenne ein bisschen natürlich
kennen andere viel besser aber wir
hatten aber zumal was wir miteinander zu
tun und unsere kinder so bekannt
war ich mal was man sagen soll ich habe
immer gedacht jemand wie er kann nichts
böses tun oder ist ja jetzt noch nicht
das schwer zu sagen aber es
ist komisch wegen noch finanziellen
sache ins gefängnis zu müssen und das
wünscht ihm überhaupt nicht und wie
gesagt menschlich tut mir sehr leid und
ich kenne ihn als sehr netten tollen
menschen der unser aller idol war und
wahrscheinlich auch bleiben wird weil
ich habe so viele schöne erinnerungen an
ihn und die werden bleiben und ob da
jetzt eine englische richterin ein
urteil gefällt was richtig oder falsch
ist kann nicht beurteilen ich finde es
schade aber wo es wird immer ein idol
bleiben
boris wird immer ein idol bleiben sagen
die einen andere stimmen sehen das
anders und bayerns ministerpräsident und
tennis sein markus söder hat sich jetzt
auch zum bäcker urteil geäußert und auch
er sieht becker als ein jugendidol
ich selbst bin seit meiner jugend ein
großer tennisfan deswegen leide ich auch
sehr das podest becker diesen fehler
gemacht hat und jetzt dafür ins
gefängnis muss weil das war das idol der
jugend das sind ja offenkundig fehler
passiert man muss auch für die fehler
den man macht im leben ein stehen
trotzdem ist es extrem schade und trotz
dieses fehlers für den jetzt
verantwortung übernehmen muss bleibt er
doch unvergessen der tennisheld für
deutschland weder davor noch danach
hatte ist eine solche begeisterung für
tennis gegeben ich selber wurde an dem
tag mit vereinsmeister
ich glaube im doppel damals als er
wimbledon gewonnen hat weiß ich noch
ganz genau hin zu fahren aus meiner
generation sind alle pokerfans auch
geblieben und es ist ein thema bei
sportlern sport ist das eine das
ergebnis was anderes